[Música]
muy bien y ahora vamos a nuestra sección
de economía de la mano de Daniela
hablando Daniela lo veíamos en el
informativo la Unión Europea prepara
este décimo paquete de sanciones contra
Rusia Claro que sí Ángela pues se va a
cumplir ya un año el próximo 24 de
febrero de esta invasión a Ucrania y
occidente intenta ahogar todavía más en
las finanzas rusas con un nuevo lote de
sanciones
representantes de los 27 países de la
Unión Europea se reunieron en Bruselas
este miércoles para discutir nuevas
sanciones que ascenderían a casi 12.000
millones de dólares en comercio perdido
en este nuevo paquete que debe ser
aprobado por todos los estados miembro
se están sugiriendo restricciones sobre
algunos componentes electrónicos y de
doble uso utilizados en Rusia hablamos
por ejemplo de drones misiles también de
helicópteros el caucho y el asfalto
también se agregarían a esta lista de
importaciones prohibidas desde ese país
también el servicio árabe de Rusia today
en territorio comuni tario Pero esta vez
hay un ingrediente adicional Y es que
van a agregar a Irán por supuestamente
ayudar al kremlin en esta guerra
la guardia Revolucionaria de Irán ha
estado proporcionando a Rusia drones
para atacar la infraestructura en
Ucrania por lo tanto ahora Estamos
agregando siete entidades iraníes a
nuestras sanciones de doble uso ahora
están bajo una prohibición total de
vender artículos sensibles a Rusia
y estamos listos para enumerar más
entidades iraníes y de terceros países
que están proporcionando tecnologías
sensible a Moscú repasamos la noticia de
Louis vuitto que tiene nuevo director
creativo para hombres
alta prestigiosa casa de moda francesa
escogió al cantante Williams quien saltó
a la fama en el negocio de la música
como productor y cantante con éxitos
como Happy para la película de Disney de
speakabo Me too que le valió una
nominación al Oscar Williams ha ganado
13 premios Grammy y fue juez en el
popular concurso de canto de voice ahora
pues pasará de los escenarios a las
pasarelas y encabezará la dirección
artística de los diseños de ropa
masculina de esta marca Louis Vuitton
quien también además va a ocupar un
puesto que quedó vacante hace más de un
año con la muerte de bergel Apple su
primera colección saldrá en junio
próximo esto en el marco de la semana de
la moda masculina de París y en un
cambio de radical de tema hablemos de
los resultados empresariales del 2022
que se siguen conociendo en Wall Street
Claro recordemos que todos los
resultados se deben conocer antes de
marzo resultados de diciembre esta vez
hablamos del casi duopolio que existe en
el mercado global de bebidas
carbonatadas pepsico y coca-cola ambos
han tenido sólidos resultados pero se
quejan del incremento de Los costos
Aunque este aumento se fue directamente
a los consumidores coca-cola tuvo
ingresos globales 11 por ciento
superiores al año pasado hasta los 43
mil millones de dólares y subió sus
precios globales en 11% mientras que los
consumidores de pepsico dieron alzas del
14% en sus precios esto lo dice conforme
anual con corte a diciembre que mostró
un incremento del 8,7% en sus ingresos
que son del doble de los de coca-cola
porque cuenta con una gama más amplia de
productos la mala noticia para algunos
es que ya coca-cola dijo que seguirá
subiendo de precio y tiene la fortuna
que la demanda pues no se ha agotado No
pues como si es Adictiva vamos con Los
indicadores las bolsas de reaccionaron
mixtas al dato de inflación de Estados
Unidos que no fue tan bueno como se
esperaba el gran ganador fue el dólar
que sube en los mercados el día de hoy
en Asia las bolsas cerraron en rojo
sobre todo en Hong Kong que perdió más
del 1,4% en Europa están avanzando las
jornada Las bolsas a Londres lo animó el
dato de inflación de Reino Unido que fue
del 10,1% anual en enero
y finalmente su cifra del día para el
cierre bueno la cifra del día tiene que
ver con los
18.420 millones de dólares las
exportaciones francesas de vinos y otros
licores como champán y konak y coñac en
2022 pero también le Tengo otras
noticias bursátiles Ángela antes de que
acabar son muy rápidas primero Subway
que dijo que posiblemente iba a vender
su negocio entró en un en un acuerdo con
JP Morgan para que le ayude a mirar qué
tan viable es vender su negocio en todo
el mundo Así mismo Twitter la red social
dominada por el multimillonario
sudafricano y los Mask que dijo que para
finales de 2023 esperaba haber
encontrado un nuevo sitio para la
compañía Gracias por haber encontrado el
espacio Daniela y nos vemos mañana Así
es Ángela